sergeant Allah David Johnson was killed
in action in Nazaire on october 4th he
was one of four US soldiers who died in
this Isis ambush that has been the
subject of a lot of controversy over the
last week the controversy has also grown
or become specific and focused on a
trump phone call with the widow of LA
David Johnson Myesha johnson was donald
trump respectful during the phone call
was he empathetic
according to congresswoman Frederica
Wilson Donald Trump was an absolute
disaster telling the widow that her
husband must have known what he signed
up for now the Trump White House and
Trump himself have disputed the account
they've disputed it for days or even a
week but now the widow herself has
broken her silence and confirmed yeah
the story is exactly as congresswoman
Frederica Wilson told it is anybody
surprised the widow saying here to
George Stephanopoulos that getting a
phone call from Donald Trump made things
worse for her not better what did you
say to the president I didn't I didn't
say anything I just listed but you were
upset when you got off the phone oh very
very upsetting hurt very it made me cry
even worse obviously a phone call from
Donald Trump when you're a grieving
widow makes things worse from you it's
hard to think of any situation where a
phone call from Donald Trump is going to
make things better for you and obviously
as we learn from Maya Johnson Frederica
Wilson was 100% correct in her account
of how this phone call went president
said that the congresswoman was lying
about the phone call whatever miss
Wilson say was not fabricated what she
said was a hundred percent correct
it was Master Sergeant nail me my aunt
my uncle and the driver and miss Wilson
in a car the phone was on speakerphone
why will you fabricate something like
that
is there anything you'd like to say to
the president now no I don't know I
don't have nothing just hating restraint
I hear restraint in the voice of my Asia
Johnson as well as significant grief
Myesha Johnson buried her husband this
past weekend while Donald Trump was
playing golf and after this interview
Trump takes to Twitter and he's battling
a Goldstar Widow refuting her account of
the conversation saying quote I had a
very respectful conversation with the
widow of Sergeant Lee David Johnson and
spoke his name from the beginning
without hesitation how do you win a
fight with a Goldstar Widow this is one
of Donald Trump's most vile tweets to
date the grieving widow of a military
service member in the midst of extreme
grief and two days after her husband's
funeral flies to New York to be
interviewed to clear up confusion
partially because the president is
saying Frederico Wilson's account of the
phone call is made up and she then
leaves the interview and the President
of the United States is on Twitter
implying she is a liar and the
respectful right-wing which supports the
troops they've been caught creating fake
facebook posts impersonating Myesha
Johnson on Sunday ABC News said that
there were posts on Facebook supposedly
from Aisha Johnson which were not posts
from her I won't even give those posts
more attention by telling you what was
in them and reading them to you how
depraved do you have to be to
impersonate the grieving widow of a
military service member it's disgusting
and I've made it clear we don't want to
normalize george w bush I've been super
clear anytime I mentioned even george w
bush wouldn't have done something so
stupid it's not praise of george w bush
it's just showing how insane things have
become under the normalisation of
President Trump but I can't think of
another president of an of another
president that would start picking
fights with military widows Goldstar
widows gold star dad's not obama not
george w bush or Clinton or Bush one or
Carter keep on going on
forced error once again all of this
preventable if your Trump release a
statement about me share right away
don't attack Obama when talking about
knee chair don't tweet about the phone
calls at all and if you tweet say simply
I was honored to speak with my Isha
Johnson she's entitled to feel however
she feels at the time because this is a
time of such grief for her I wish her
the best and thank her husband for his
service almost anything would have been
better than what Donald Trump has
actually done and done and my thoughts
are with Myesha Johnson I hope [ __ ] that
she has or builds a strong support
network probably finds a good therapist
I can't even imagine being in this
situation and you know I this can't be
good for the morale of other service
members right imagine that you're a
service member and you're in a dangerous
situation somewhere on the planet and
you see how Trump handles this are you
going to feel confident that if you
don't make it home that your spouse is
going to be treated with dignity and
respect I certainly wouldn't be
confident of that